[Music]
ask me any question let me give your
cheat sheet the hide is that oh I just
had to remember what the two titles were
and then you can just riff and I know I
don't have to worry it's jazz it's a
jazz composition yeah it's not it's not
classical or cuz I get it believe me
well here we are or in the now guru
corner resumes
it's more like I feel like guru corner
is is the incorrect designation for this
it should be like guru universe or at
least multiverse all right yeah at least
guru circle yeah that we know no corners
yeah no heart no hard edges yeah yeah
just fastness yeah because you know as
we know the word guru is the GU is the
darkness and Naru is the light and so
guru means the the light that comes out
of darkness which means the the
something that comes out of nothing aha
what do you like how do you shoulder
that responsibility of kind of harboring
that moniker guru a lot of people
bristle at that I know you know we're
actually we're actually creating an app
and we thought okay it could be called
guru then we thought oh that might be
you know that might be good for some but
not for all and so we're kind of playing
and then we thought we'll call it frog
you know just because it has no meaning
except that you know frogs represent
transformation from from one way of
breathing to another way of breathing
and we all know we all know your
affinity for frogs we do and because
when I was a little child because of my
larger eyes my nickname was frog it
started out as kind of a bullying thing
hey froggy you know but it turned out I
and I embraced it and it was fun so now
we're kind of feeling the name of Guru
frog mmm it kind of takes the Frog and
puts the Goodwin and it takes the edge
off of guru and right yeah if you're
sort of playing with it and not taking
it too seriously
which is exactly what we're talking
about today and that is the seed of
infinity as opposed to the vastness of
infinity so break that down for me a
little bit well within a seed is the
plant but within the plant are multiple
seeds and within the multiple seeds are
their plants so all of that is
registered within the seed that's one of
the reasons why they always talk about
you know the universe within the mustard
seed mm-hmm and so within every seed is
not only infinity going forward but it's
also infinity going backward because of
all the seeds that it took to create
that seed and there's no net there's no
necessary point of beginning yeah its
ultimate potential looking forward and
its ultimate legacy from what's it from
once it was created yeah and the seed is
made up of the heart which is all of the
possibility and the shell which is all
of the protection and if you look around
your life you'll notice that some people
live in the seed and some people live in
the shell and those that live in the
shell are more attuned to being
protected and those that live in the
seed are more in tune to being projected
out into what they can do and a lot of
times people will have big plans you
have big plans I have big plans a lot of
people have big plans but then the
moment they begin to launch those big
plans they go into shell mode which
means that they're trying to protect the
aspects of their big plan but what we
have to recognize is in the buddha
called this
the middle path if we walk kind of in
the center of those two extremes on the
spectrum
we'll be able to protect what we need to
it moments that we need to and will meet
will be able to project out there at
other times so I like to think of breath
as being that igniter of the seed hmm
you as a triathlete as an extreme
athlete have such a strong relationship
with your breath I mean I'm sure that
there's certain times that there's only
two things happening and one's the
movement and the breathing
well it's interesting to kind of track
the science that's coming out now around
breath and the importance of breath it's
something that we really don't put much
mindfulness into we just yeah we breathe
and what's the big deal what's the
difference between breathing and paying
attention to the breath and in that is
its own seed this own multiverse of
potentiality exactly but what I was
thinking about when you were talking was
a different way of looking at it or
perhaps an analogous view which is the
outer coating of the seed the protective
shell feels like how we imagined the
self or being other than or being
separate from and the seed within it is
is the dissolution of the self and the
acknowledgment or the greater awareness
of the oneness that we share I'm sitting
here listening and I'm gone is this me
talking back to me and then you're
listening and you're going is this me
talking it's just me spending all this
time with you it's washing it sloshing
yes the the the potentiality of that of
that centerpiece is the disillusion of
the restrictions of identity mm-hmm I'm
sure that in when you know the old
proverbial hit the wall right when in
your extreme events you actually
get that that bursts of something that
comes from somewhere it's a reduction of
that identity the identity I'm exhausted
I think that whether it's through
extreme athletic endeavors or meditation
or you know an ayahuasca trip these are
all vehicles for or breath they're all
vehicles for tapping into the truth
which is the illusion of the self and
other necessities but the greater
consciousness that permeates all and so
when you tap into that you know extra
reservoir of energy for me that comes
with the breaking down of the mental
barriers that I construct that separate
me from everything and I think that that
you know that can be achieved through
breath through meditation and these are
all things that you had experience with
but the recognition the awareness the
knowledge the understanding that that
consciousness is not something that
resides within our brain or between our
ears but is something that that is you
know a force that extends through all
matter in various forms and we tend to
restrict our understanding of
consciousness to the human experience
but but it's a much it's a vastly
broader reality that I think now we're
starting to kind of grapple with and and
try to understand I don't know that we
never will but I'm interested in kind of
where your thinking is with that well
when you yeah we are beginning to
grapple with it in large numbers in the
past oftentimes what would happen is
that a person would have an awakening
and that around that person would be
would form a large movement
and these individuals would become icons
of the movement and then with you know
the normal forces of ownership so to
speak those icons of a movement would
become exclusive unattainable capacity
is unachievable what's happening now and
this is why your podcast is so important
and also so popular what's happening now
is that everybody that is at that level
of awareness where they're starting to
experience consciousness rather than
just their individuation they're
realizing that there's a calling inside
there's a purpose inside and it's not
restricted to a religious dogma it's not
restricted to any single form of
spiritual dogma either it's just this
relationship very much like the
difference between your laptop when it's
just within itself which is its identity
and the laptop when it actually has
access to Wi-Fi and then from Wi-Fi it
has access to the world wide web as they
call it right yeah there's a there's a
great democratization of ideas and
states of awareness that's happening
right now as a direct result of the
internet which comes with all of its
baggage and problems of course but it's
an it's a way it's a means it's an
avenue for transcending the perils of
human crafted institutions that
inevitably devolve or you know find
themselves you know fallible because of
the humans that created them and and
ultimately corrupted and elitist and
exclusions are interpreted the creation
mmm-hmm right yeah and if we can remove
those walls and make make ideas freely
available what is the need for the four
walls of the institution and also think
about the you know the I M the I M is
the attitude
of every great master you know I am in
that in that awakening they recognize
that they are the infinity so that's the
I am well the difference between today
and days gone by is the in days gone by
the attitude was oh he is but now in
today's world the attitude is oh he's
showing me that I am mm-hmm and that's
that's a key because what we need is
millions tens of millions of messiahs
and prophets all resonating with love
and purity and clarity so that no one
individual can be taken down the problem
with that is that humans being tribal by
nature like to gravitate to certain
silos and we're kind of hardwired to
identify a leader among us divest
ourselves of our of our power to you
know to be subsumed by someone that we
perceive as more than or better than or
higher than listening to you I just
thought well then I'm I'm an electrician
because it's hardwired Maeve I'm the
electrician that goes around and cuts
the wires because I'm here to stir the
pot you're here to stir the pot and what
you just said is important because as we
stir the pot it's important for us to
recognize what's in the pot and if
what's in the pot is the hardwiring of
tribal nature then that's what we have
to address mm-hmm and we have to figure
out some way of addressing it without
attacking it yeah yes I sort of canvass
you know I'm sorry I'm a student of
internet culture and the ecosystems that
kind of take place online and what I see
is not really a war
but this kind of competition of ideas
that takes place that is empowering
people but at the same time there's a
counter force pushing back which is it's
separating people by driving them into
various tribes and triggering that a
neat thing that we have inside of us as
humans to identify ourselves by way of
our tribe and and as separate from
whatever other tribe that's purporting
another idea
so with this freedom of idea exchange
also comes this countervailing force of
increased and intensified tribal
cultures mmm and for us who are
recognizing it for what it is we're a
little bit like the supervisor in a
daycare center you know the kids are
into it you know and they're into the
fact that so ins I better not use a name
because somebody out there listening is
going to feel personal about it but
so-and-so took the shovel and there was
only one shovel right and so as
supervisors we had we either have to
provide more shovels or show how you can
scoop the sand with your hands and do
all kinds of different things because
we're the ones that are watching with an
awareness that is not more special not
more important but more progressed so
that we can watch the fact that okay
this has caused a fracturing of the
unity and they're starting to tribal
eyes around this particular issue a very
wise man once said it's called an
elevated paradox when you have these
polarizing ideas that to take part of
one part of another is the compromise
but then everyone feels satisfied and
dissatisfied but if you take a third
position that actually uses all of both
because it is a conflict and in a
conflict there's tremendous energy it's
called the elevated paradox and so you
take that paradoxical perspective which
is elevated from both of these forces
and all of a sudden no one feels like
they gave anything up everyone feels
like they gain something now I'm not
saying that's easy mm-hmm
but that's our task in the world and
knowing that a seed has infinity within
it
that infinity also means that the seed
of each moment has the ability to go for
identity which is at tribal orientation
but it also has the ability to go to the
to the dissolving of the barriers right
the barrier around the shell around the
husk around whatever it is and I find
that people that are focusing on the
differences are focusing on the shell
people that are focusing on the sameness
or the the cominis are focusing on the
seed and if we get if we in train more
people to focus on the seed that they
have brought to this planet then we'll
find out you know let's continue the
metaphor we'll find out how that garden
looks with all of these seeds growing I
look around our garden and and there's
weeds growing you know and when I go to
pull them out or cut them they look up
at me and they say things like you know
I mean obviously I'm speaking in
metaphor here but you know they say
things like so guru Singh who identified
that as a plant that you want to keep
and me as a seed that you want to take
out and that's something that we have to
be able to do with the ideas that our
tribal izing people is to show how they
all fit in the same garden so how do we
do that by listening and by entertaining
our unknowing capacities
the capacities first to step into like
you and I we sit down we're not reading
off a teleprompters were basically
reflecting off of each other's ideas and
like you said a moment ago when you were
talking I was thinking that's how we do
it we do it by allowing ourselves to
become moldable while still maintaining
a center point not that we're just you
know being able to be dispersed across
the universe but that center point is
the center point perhaps of commonality
or the center point of harmony or what
have you I love this idea of the sea
holding the potential energy for an
infinite number of possibilities and
choices and identities and you know
future outcomes and when you kind of
take a step back from that and really
think about what a seed is it is made up
of atoms that are Stardust that date
back to the Big Bang we're all comprised
of of you know these elemental materials
that are ageless and timeless and part
wave and part matter in in in a myriad
of ways that were only beginning to
understand and perhaps may never truly
understand and the more we can telescope
out from you know what I have to do
tomorrow and that guy I have to call
back and the email that I didn't return
and the text message that you sent me
that one responded to for two weeks or
whatever I find not only beautiful
mystery but also comfort in that and
that allows me to eradicate the walls
that separate myself from somebody else
who is walking around with a very
different worldview that I have have you
come across those those individuals that
will ask you what's the difference
between this and that right because
that's how they can identify things is
by differentiation
and my response to those people is okay
well let me talk about the commonality
because if somebody wants to know about
Judaism Christianity and Islam and
Buddhism and Sikhism and Hinduism
they'll want to know okay what are the
differences between them
and in that way they can make clear
identities what about if we were to just
focus on what's the sameness what's the
threads that are common to them all and
I think that that training children at a
very early age not to be differentiators
but to be unifiers would be a step you
know because this thing isn't going to
happen in the next ten years yeah I
think that interracial that that we that
there was an evolutionary advantage to
the human brains predisposition for
categorization right like we're very
good at drawing distinctions and for fur
for a number of reasons I would imagine
that allowed us to survive and thrive
like there's something about that
predisposition to categorize and
differentiate that allows us to make
sense of a world so that we can
procreate you know and and not get
killed by a predator or something like
that
so when you say training I think that's
very true I think we have to override
that predisposition to broaden our
conscious awareness to understand like
oh this is what my brain does this is
what you know I am hardwired to do but
in order to truly thrive we have to
override that programming to develop a
broader awareness but we don't
necessarily have to anymore draw these
hard lines in these categories in order
to in order to live in the world there's
an evolutionary shift Charles Darwin
described it quite perfectly in what you
were just illustrating and that was the
survival of the fittest
because life was a competition you were
defining your territory
you were defining your identity now with
this many people on this small of a
planet because we're reducing the
resources faster than they're being
reproduced it's no longer the survival
of the fittest but it's the survival of
those who fit together and we've seen it
in a lot of the other animal worlds the
you know the horses that cows the
elephants the giraffes etc is that
they're coming together to work for and
with each other is more important now
than going it alone mm-hmm there are
those in our societies that are still
believing and promoting the idea of go
it alone do it your way stand your
ground you know all of these ways this
is old school
it's also a new law it's also an
illusion yes but it was an illusion as
you described a moment ago that got us
to this point that allowed us to live
beyond the threats of the saber-tooth
tiger and what have you but now it's
about fitting together not not being the
most fit mm-hmm yeah this nation was
founded on that ideal self-sufficiency
you know pursuit of you know your dreams
and and the idea of you know individual
liberty it's all about like supporting
the individual to do their thing and go
in and go it alone is kind of packed
into that idea but when you look at the
most successful species they are the
most intertwined and interdependent with
the ecosystems that support them and
these things all work in harmony and
they've been around a lot longer than we
have and you know we don't live
symbiotically on this planet you know
we're living in a very unsustainable way
and unless we find a way to create
equanimity and symbiosis with every
living entity that we share this planet
with I don't see us finding a successful
solution for long term
survival the human race exactly we do
not we do not survive much if at all
past this century as a human species if
we don't dramatically change and what
we're experiencing in amongst the seeds
of infinity is those seeds that just
want to maintain their individual
identity which means that they're
pulling their shell around themselves so
you see it in nationalism you see it in
you know there is no such thing as race
but to use the expression you see it in
racism you see it in in the gender
differentiation you see it in the
restrictive nature of how religious
orders are so far behind the real
consciousness of what needs to be in
life where we're starting to welcome a
variety and a diversity into this world
what you are just saying there is that
as we who are the observers of what is
taking place under the pressures of
today's world where resources are
dwindling and survival is tentative
we're the ones that have to be the
supervisors I look at the earth as a
daycare center you know it's like got a
lot of little kids that are all in adult
bodies but they're just children
fighting over scraps of land you know
fighting over titles and importances and
we have to come into that daycare center
and not attack but provide this
commonality because once everybody
starts to get their fundamental needs
met which is happiness and you know true
nutrition
plant-based mm-hmm no more blood based
nutrition right because blood base makes
us aggressive makes us feel like we've
been attacked because we're tasting
blood and but plant-based and the
attitude of really creating what you
used a word a moment ago the equanimity
the equality of us all and then be able
to stand up in the midst of that
equality and demonstrate that there are
some ways in which it can be done more
readily mm-hmm so walk me through the
process of deconstructing these false
identities that we've created so that we
can step into this higher awareness well
I would I would hesitate to even imply
although I know it's true that they're
false identities because the moment I
would imply that it's a false identity
I'd have to deal with somebody who's
claiming otherwise right all right how
about incomplete then so what I heard
right what I would really become more
inclined toward is the Pied Piper
routine which is to take the seeds of my
infinity and take the breasts that I can
use to invoke those seeds and identify
some of its projection with each moment
with each day with each week etc and I
would begin to build an alternative
reality closer aligned with the unity
and the lack of differentiation and then
I would work to stimulate it to the
point where it's successful in the eyes
of those who have three dimensional
thinking four dimensional thinking time
is money
and become so successful in the process
of creating this alternate illusion that
in it might not be the ultimate illusion
it might be just an alternate illusion
but it would be attractive like the Pied
Piper you know they would see success
they would see that all of their needs
can be met under this condition in the
past what spiritual leaders would do is
that they would go and renounce the
world and go off and live with nothing
no that's not attractive today nobody is
going to say well I guess the road to
peace is to all give up everything and
that's that's nonsense
so let's create an alternative reality
in which we're living in harmony we're
living in unity but we're also living
successfully that's a big chat that's
yeah yes the renunciant aspect of that
aside that seems to be what you're
saying seems to be rooted in that
traditional idea of Buddhism where the
way you know the best way to change the
world is to is to change yourself right
it starts with that like fertilize that
seed within so that it can blossom and
thrive I was hoping you'd come back yeah
I'm bringing I always bring it back and
that you know in the way that you
described it as the Pied Piper you
become you know in an example for a
different way to live
and by thriving in the world not outside
of the world in that alternate paradigm
that you become a magnet or a lightning
rod or others that are starting to you
know fibrate on your frequency yeah and
one of the things that we use and I
teach is that our body parts have
chemistry and that chemistry when it's
secreted into the bloodstream is called
peptides and hormones and every part of
our body has a has a not a
Niq but has a rather individual angle of
the chemistry mm-hmm and some parts of
our body when they get stimulated and
secrete into the bloodstream they'll
make us more defensive defensiveness is
not a bad thing if it's used in the
proper amounts what it actually does is
it gives us the ability to see
differentiations that are important like
where's the edge of the cliff when
you're running along a mountain trail
where is the centerline when you're
driving along a highway and so those
differentiations are important there are
parts in our body that actually give us
a lot of commonality a lot of those
potti body parts are attached to the
breathing process the diaphragm for one
is a major component of inspiration as a
matter of fact the word inspire means to
take a breath so this diaphragm if it
becomes loose and pliable
almost it's the largest muscle in our
body if it becomes loose and pliable
then it starts to secrete the peptides
of inspiration when you're inspired
you're friendlier you're more loving
you're more caring you're more willing
to share and so people that have deep
breathing attitudes right when you come
off a run and you've been breathing
diaphragmatic ly
you're not thinking who is that jerk
about it you know you're coming off and
you're feeling like you're kind of like
one with everyone you know somebody
gives you a foil blanket another one
gives you a hug you don't care who it is
hugging you you're kind of like one with
everyone but that's because you're in
deep inspiration there are other parts
in our body for example the heart is
core in French right so it's courage but
it's also will you know they say the the
willingness the one who had more heart
in the event and it's also hope so you
have hope will and
courage in the heart so if you get your
heart you know uptake the rate increased
now you're pumping more hope will and
courage into your system if you're
breathing deeply you've got more
inspiration and the polarity to that is
that languishing in indolence which
really starts to shut down everything
and then there is no commonality so you
look at the western lifestyle you look
at the industrial lifestyle the
industrial lifestyle is all about the
suck coziest mattress the coziest chair
the coziest car seat the coziest is
everything is about your your docile
form being comfortable in that idle
state what about if we just ever so
slightly were to generate popular events
that increase the use of these body
parts that would create commonality so
everybody needs to breathe and exercise
everybody really exercise and eat a
plant-based diet there we go we're done
our work here is done we we I was
telling you before the podcast we
recently returned from from Italy where
I love those pictures you guys at that
super long table I was beautiful oh we
had such a good group this year and one
of the things that we do every time is
we we take the group through holotropic
breathing oh not on the first day like
it's after we've all kind of connected
and we've been doing yoga and we've been
trail running and we've been eating you
know we've were where we've become a
congealed unit at this point and there's
an intimacy amongst you know this unit
and then Julie takes takes this group
through a pretty intense holotropic
breathing exercise which is something a
lot of these people had never done
before and almost unanimously everybody
has
some form of transcendent psychedelic
experience as a result the DMZ in the
braids it is crazy
yeah literally by just by virtue of
nothing other than an intense breathing
exercise people are transported to you
know dimensions beyond anything I could
have imagined and then we sit around and
share our experiences and it is just
wild what people like people that are
not you know these are not necessarily
people that are showing up at Yoga West
to hear to hear the sermons of guru
Singh these are you know military
personnel corporate executives people
that for whom this is a unique and
brand-new experience with which they
don't have previous experience and you
know they're talking about I became you
know an eagle and I was soaring over a
valley and I was visited upon by he you
know like very elaborate narratives yeah
and for them it was visceral and real
and this is breath it is freely
available to all of us and what I see in
that is that to bring it back to the
seed that there is an infinite number of
potential realities and experiences that
are available to all of us with a little
bit of training and guidance so as those
electricians wandering amongst the
tribal nature of human beings cutting
the hard wires that tend us toward
tribalism those are the experiences that
become unique and common simultaneously
because when you sit around and have
those sharings and you know here's a
military guy career military man can't
believe I'm saying this but like I
became a buffalo or like exactly it
gives everyone else the permission to
explain their experience yeah and when
you have
the permission the self inaugurated
permission to explain your experience
you start to realize that you're
actually having more experience than
you're even explaining to yourself and
that you are by expressing it to others
by sharing it with others you're getting
more of a handle on what it is that
you've just gone through
that's why journaling is also really a
key verbal journaling and also just
writing it into a into a stationery book
yeah I mean for me it's instructive in
in the sense that it it demonstrates
unequivocably to me that that
consciousness is so much more vast and
nuanced and complicated and mysterious
than the human experience of our daily
lives I'm reading this book right now
called conscious by Annika Harris you
would love this book she's coming in
next week for the podcast this is a very
evidence-based analysis or primer on the
nature of consciousness evidence based
on what what from from the perspective
of from like a neurological perspective
less mystical but nonetheless
fascinating and she really tries to get
at the root of what exactly
consciousness is and she deconstruct and
analyzes the various theories that are
out there and the conclusion is really a
we don't really understand it be it's
not necessarily localized in human mind
and it's not limited to human beings or
even sentient animals and she goes into
this elaborate description of the plant
kingdom and as we know the way that
trees communicate with each other and
the the symbiosis with with the mycelium
and everything that takes place for you
know these forests to exist the way that
they do exactly and she she has this she
she goes down this rabbit hole on this
theory called pan psychism which is
really this idea that that consciousness
is in everything even Eve
inanimate matter it goes down to the you
know subatomic level of what's actually
happening and how little we understand
and how dangerous it is for the
scientific community to actually embrace
this idea because it is so mind-blowing
but it's utterly fascinating and and it
left me with this sense that we may
never understand consciousness but that
consciousness is not a localized thing
that exists within our bodies but is
something far more vast and
interconnected consciousness is a seed a
seed of infinity a non-identified seed
right no specific identity but it's the
vast potential that's the same as in a
seed because two oak two oak acorns
right two oaks eads you put one in a
forest that's very crowded and it will
grow in a particular way to accommodate
the crowd that same seed put it into a
forest that is actually quite sparse and
it will grow to extend itself into the
sparse nature of the forest same seed
same programming two people tuned into
consciousness one with a genetic history
of crowding another with a genetic
history of you know only one child only
you know one child only one child only
one child and you end up with using the
same infinite source of nutrient these
two different expressions right now one
is not wrong one is not right
they're both what they are this is in
fact what we're moving towards the more
we will understand the more we study
consciousness the more that we're going
to be able to get along because we're
going to like you were saying a moment
ago recognize that it's non-local
and so how do I call it mine how do I
say my higher consciousness maybe it's
just higher consciousness maybe it's
just the reverberations think of the
Buddha when he was sitting by the river
and he said if I focus on the part of
the river that is right here that I'm
focusing on that which is always the
same this part of the river always the
same but if I focus on the fact that I
am the river then I'm at my destination
simultaneously that I'm at my source and
that is literally what consciousness is
consciousness is at the destination and
also at the source and who knows maybe
those are both the same place yeah I'm
trying to wrap my head around that right
now because you think of a river right
the river is going down the mountain the
river is complete if you're an
individual bubble on that River you're
making the journey down that which is
already complete mmm and so in our
psyche you are talking a moment ago
about dealing with our daily routines as
opposed to expanding into our
consciousness and our conscious
awareness when we expand into our
conscious awareness where the whole
river or were a larger portion of the
river and when we're just focusing on
our individual daily routines were that
bubble that's bouncing down and going
over the rapids and getting swept up and
etc I think that's most of us most of
the time myself included I would think
that that is most everybody by design
most of the time yourself excluded you
are just more aware of when you get
sucked into that trap and so it
registers very distinctly for you but
there's no way that you are of that
nature by nature you wouldn't be doing
these podcasts you wouldn't be living
where you live you wouldn't be doing
what you do but for me I mean that is my
default and yes maybe I have moments of
awareness where I can step outside of
that or at least recognize is that what
you are just I don't
awareness all any of us are that's the
seed I love it it's so difficult though
it is it is a like it's a practice right
you have these moments of broader
awareness and then you then lapse back
into the daily routine where you're
caught up in whatever's going on in your
visionary your auditory field or
whatever it is and you have to keep
light in the same way with meditation
you have to keep returning to the breath
or whatever you know modality that you
use for that for me awareness is the
same thing I have to constantly remind
myself and I will go through
tremendously extended periods of time
without that awareness before I have to
remember and bring myself back to that
broader awareness and I look at it like
how can I live in that space and I just
push the envelope out a little bit
further and why is it so difficult like
why am I so predisposed to get caught up
in the minutia or you know replaying
some narrative in my head about what
happened yesterday or the fear and
anxiety I have about what's happening
tomorrow why can't I exist
extemporaneously like in that in that
space of oneness when you think of our
our theme of today and that within the
seed is infinity then that means that
within that seed is the fixation on
minutiae as well as the vast awareness
of the commonality of the oneness and so
it's they're all happening
simultaneously our parasympathetic
nervous system and our sympathetic
nervous system will differentiate
between them and so our sympathetic
nervous system can be turned over to our
parasympathetic nervous system by using
more of our diaphragm by literally when
we feel ourselves being drawn in to that
so
that you know that worrisome state we do
something a daily practice it's like
when you feel like let's say you're
kayaking and you feel that your boat is
being swept down into a channel that you
definitely have not had good experiences
with so then you guide it by putting in
an alternative force same thing holds
true for our daily lives when we're
aware most people get swept into these
moments of you know fixation on minutiae
and and and complaining and
problem-solving etc etc most people get
swept into those things unconsciously
you get swept into them consciously
you're aware that you're going in not
always but guys that you eventually do
discover and then you know that you have
some tools at your disposal to work your
way out of it you know after you've said
a few few complaints that's what is you
know you walk through a smoke-filled
room you're gonna smell like a cigar
smoker when you come out of that room
and you're gonna have it in your hair
and you're gonna have it on your clothes
and you're have it in your lungs so you
got to go through a cleansing process
and it's just the same way in the world
at large because there are so many
mental constructs they're driving down
the road in their car they're cutting
you off they're trying to gain a
three-second advantage and a line of
cars they're doing it all the time
the majority of those people are doing
it because they're born to do it
you're doing it or you're getting caught
in it because you're born to observe it
and there's a difference between the
born to do it and the born to observe it
and then the next step after being born
to observe it is observing it and
finding an alternative to it and that's
I will say that's one of the reasons why
you interview so many profoundly
wonderful human beings is that it's in
part you
giving this gift to the world which it
truly is I have people all over the
world say hey the reason I came to your
class is because I'm a big podcast fan
of rich roll you know and it happens
every single day all over the world and
you're also doing it for your own
elevation your own and that's what makes
it so real that it doesn't feel like a
performance when people are watching
these podcasts it feels like it's your
real you're into it for real and you're
trying to discover for real and that
gives them the opportunity to do the
same by looking through from the outside
or listening through from the outside
yeah well I appreciate that I mean I I
definitely only have people on that I
want to learn from and I and I try to
maintain my teach ability and my I have
an openness to wanting to improve and
learn and so the experience is is very
much selfish in that regard but the gift
is that I get to be selfless and giving
it to the world which is it kind of
works out for everybody I guess but what
I heard in in what you just said is a
couple things I mean first of all you
know the observer aspect of what you
just spoke to just reaffirms or reminds
me how important it is to be discerning
about the environment that you choose
and I think that that you know being
consciously aware of that is freely
available to all of us like how can you
be more mindful about the company that
you keep and the communities that you
you know navigate and immerse yourself
in in the sense that that acorn is going
to grow one way in one environment and a
different way and a different one and
you want to be in the environment that's
going to promote you to thrive I think
it's super important and the other thing
is I just lost my train of ohnow I
remember what it was what I find myself
doing is is harboring judgments about
these different states of consciousness
more specifically
if I catch myself lapsing into a lack of
awareness or getting caught up in the in
the you know wave of whatever's just
happening in my moments you know getting
getting distracted by rehashing
something that happened in the past or
what's going to be happening in the
future and then I have that moment of
reckoning and I step outside of it then
I judge myself for having that partially
and then I reward myself for being in a
different state of consciousness which
then you know makes me feel or is the
kind of the trap in that is that then
you feel superior and neither of these
judgments are are true or warranted
right so for me that exercise is just as
much about trying to reserve judgment on
these various states because I think
that a higher state of consciousness is
is transcending those instincts to
categorize or qualify one state as being
better than the other yeah and but
that's very difficult like that's a
mental trap that's very challenging for
me to transcend I'm I'm really clear on
what you're describing because the the
nature of Judge is uncommon to almost
everyone that uses it there's a common
expression now where people will say I'm
not judging you I'm just observing you
right and this is what I'm observing and
that's pushing on a truth which is let
me observe the fact that you tend to
pick your nose in public I'm not talking
about you by the way I'm not talking
about rich I've done that yeah me too
but but I observe that you pick your
nose in public whoever that you is and
then if I reserve
that's bad then I'm not judging I'm
observing I'm witnessing there's an
article that I just read the other day
that married couples whether they're
same-sex or heterosexual doesn't matter
partnerships who allow themselves to
fart and burp freely in front of each
other are mentally healthier uh-huh
now that makes total sense yeah because
you're not feeling like you're going to
be judged by a very natural event the
gases come let it out
don't don't hold it in and so if we were
to come to the place where we're able to
witness not like oh I didn't see that
but no we're able to witness it we're
able to feel it we're able to hear it
we're able to see it and then not apply
the judgement to it of that's wrong or
that's right because the judgement is
that the brain and the head which is two
dimensional always looking at right
wrong good bad yes no and just go that
okay every moment is a seed and every
seed is infinity and if I were in that
same situation I might have done it
differently but who's to say that my way
is better hmm
and I go through that all the time
because I am always deconstructing just
like you are the tendency which is the
tendency to judge and you know I was
speaking with you know some great
masters over time by the way me too I'm
a constant student as well as a constant
teacher you know I don't feel that any
road is done and so in learning from the
great masters you will find that as
you've done but yourself we find that
they go through the same thing they just
have their own flavor of going through
it yeah I think when you can connect
with that it allows it allows for grace
and relaxation more gentle with with not
just yourself well the more gentle you
can be with yourself then you become
more empathetic and
with others what is it then before you
know it you're farting in front of your
spouse what is it they say you know the
in your life have pity on that
person because you're only experiencing
about one tenth of their bitterness or
their offensiveness they're experiencing
the full throw you know that when you
experience someone that is quite a jerk
be compassionate because they're
experiencing it 10 many-fold times over
yeah I found that that my ability to
have that healthy reaction in Asuna in
that kind of scenario is wholly
dependent upon how how much I I've been
practicing mindfulness and meditation
because I get that extra pause where I I
have then a choice and enough awareness
to choose how to best react or respond
but if I'm not taking care of myself
that button gets pushed and I'm right in
that paradigm where I'm just throwing it
I just react and of course that never
works out well especially for those of
us that are that are born to be more of
a leader you know people can get away
with peeing and pooping anywhere when
they're you know very very young and
thinking of age in terms of evolutionary
capacities you know those of us that are
of mastery quality we have a much
narrower field through which we can act
and not react and we will get a very
strong what is it John Lennon talked
about Instant Karma gonna get you well
if you if you like just went off on
somebody at the airport and somebody was
taking a little iPhone video of you and
that goes up on the internet that would
go viral you're done
it's over host yeah
cancel culture canceled on guru say
which role is not interviewing that guy
again that's funny and that's a that's
an interesting kind of cultural thing
that we're experiencing right now our
lack of of empathy and this knee-jerk
reaction to pile on to people who you
know make a mistake or you know do
something reprehensible and our our
inability to to find the nuance in these
things and that's not to say that people
aren't doing horrible things and should
should you know there should be
repercussions for that but I'm dismayed
by the furiosa tea with which good where
people get piled on I like that word for
curiosity yeah it serves some kind of
deep-seated emotional need that humans
have that I think we trick ourselves
into thinking make us feel better but
I'm not so sure that's the result well
isn't there that old saying that to have
the tallest building in town you can
either destroy all the other buildings
or you can build the tallest building
and oftentimes to feel as you say that a
sense of importance we need to destroy
someone yeah it's actually a current
carnivorous attitude it's actually cut
the carnivores are the ones who are
territorial
no herbivores territorial and the
carnivores are not only territorial but
they're more aggressive and that that
blood in the teeth you know between the
teeth and the gum there's those very
sensitive nerves that when they get the
blood forced in there they feel like
they're in battle and when they're in
battle they need to they need to fight
for their life and that's a little bit
of what's happening today even amongst
people who have been off you know flesh
foods and for a very blood foods you
know for a very long time it's still in
their DNA because the generations that
built their body is still vibrating in a
carnivorous way the epigenetics the
epigenetics thing yeah
all right well we have to wrap up this
edition of Guru circle circle or
multiverse well if there's only two of
us sitting here I don't know how we make
a circle but we'll do it I know I have a
feeling that we're gonna be talking
again soon I have that safe yeah
but why don't you take us up take us out
with a little music yeah you want to do
that yeah so I put this on which is a
leg warmer you know a dancers leg warmer
so and I don't chew up my guitar with my
with my bangles cool let's make sure
let's get this mic in the right place
for that and somebody once said so what
are those chords and I answer have no
idea
[Music]
I am Who I am that is
I am who you are looking
[Music]
you are who I am can you imagine that
there's only one that's a fact
and then in sanskrit it goes humming hum
to me too
[Music]
Oh mija - me too
I am Who I am instead I am whom you are
looking you are Who I am
can you imagine that there's only one
[Music]
love you my friend love you
to be continued very soon
thank you peace
[Music]